et nous sommes en direct avec et jim
michel gabriel avocat spécialiste de la
propriété intellectuelle bonjour à vous
alors s'il est normal pour des
entreprises et organisations de changer
de fournisseur
il est beaucoup plus rare de l'annoncer
publiquement et c'est pour cette raison
que ce fait attire l'attention
aujourd'hui oui tout à fait en fait le
cern s'éteint quand même secteur assez
on va dire concurrentiel en même temps
assez prestigieux ils pouvaient pas
aujourd'hui les seat donner accès à ces
données sans pouvoir les contrôler mais
après la génèse aujourd'hui de ce
revirement du cern à mon sens et surtout
de la tarification qui a fait que
nécessairement soit c'était gratuit et
il avait accès aux données le
manière comment dire normal facebook ou
alors tout simplement il avait une offre
payante il devait nécessairement payer
le cern à me réveilla us et le choix
justement de protéger ses données
parce que de tout simplement ils se sont
dits contenu du secteur d'activité il
pouvait pas se permettre justement ce
risque même facebook où on étale est
vraiment eu accès à toutes les données
du cern
oui oui nécessairement parce que en fait
tout le monde sait aujourd'hui que ce
sera l'heure de dire que même si on a le
le fait qu'on ait le patriot act et
klein d'évolution le rg pda etc
ça fait que malgré ça aujourd'hui
les données sont facilement accessibles
donc je pense qu'en terme de précaution
le cern a préféré justement se dire de
concerts des ces données en plus je
pense qu'il ya une aussi c'est un petit
peu politique
les européens et voit bien aujourd'hui
que les américains et les asiatiques ont
d'énormes possibilités d'avoir accès à
des données
vous savez comme moi que l'intelligence
artificielle permet justement beaucoup
de choses aujourd'hui et que comme c'est
un petit peu le fou en termes de
justement de développement ils se sont
dit comme ils prennent un petit peu de
retard
le cern et étant européens ils ont voulu
justement marqué leur territoire alors
cette décision du cern intervient deux
ans après la polémique
cambridge analytica et la protection des
données
quels sont selon vous plus largement
plus généralement les enjeux de ce
divorce entre le fermer facebook oui
comme je vous le disais les enjeux c'est
tout simplement c'est se dire que nous
européens on va plus être sous la mise
aujourd'hui des américains et que on va
maintenant développer nos propres
services
à ce niveau là et surtout se protéger de
sorte que justement nous donner soit en
tout cas vis-à-vis des lois qui sont
applicables en france notamment et en
europe
on a une plus grande protection est seul
on voit ce qu'on se dirigea vers
l'abandon et d'utilisation de facebook
et de ce genre d'applications au sein du
monde professionnel
comment est ce que vous voyez les choses
en tout cas alors je pense que ça c'est
un choix d'une entreprise parce que vous
voyez par exemple nestlé a choisi
justement de continuer leur place et par
rapport à ça donc je pense que certaines
entreprises qui sont un petit peu
sensible dans certains secteurs vont
nécessairement effectivement peut-être
abandonné
en revanche les entreprises ont réduit
en plus classique de consommation où il
ya moins entre guillemets de secrets aux
brevets etc
elles vont continuer a effectivement à
travailler les crises book et je pense
que facebook avait encore de belles
années devant
devant elle en plus gagnés développement
maintenant effectivement qui vont faire
que facebook va peut-être réinvestir
dans un petit un autre un autre
qui va lui même développé quelque chose
de plus sécurisé donc oui je pense que
dans facebook a encore de belles années
peut-être que des services et des
secteurs peu sensible on va dire où ils
vont peut-être abandonné facebook oui
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
du michel gabriel avocat spécialiste de
la propriété intellectuelle